today I want to talk about four key
areas in which Google cloud can help
mobile developers desktop developers or
any developer code build run and observe
their applications better using Google
cloud platform and we're gonna focus on
four key areas and there are other areas
these are just the four that we've
chosen in the short 40 minutes that we
have today the first is code we're going
to talk about how we can leverage Google
cloud services to build back-end systems
to support our front-end mobile and
desktop applications next we'll talk
about how we can leverage Google cloud
artificial intelligence and machine
learning technologies to build
intelligence and business logic into our
applications then we'll talk about how
you can build and publish your
applications leveraging the power of the
cloud and finally after we published our
applications we'll talk about how we can
gain insights into how they're
performing and how they're communicating
with one another by talking about
observability in order to do this my
colleague Dale and I have come up with
this idea for a fictitional application
application it's a food delivery
application now we know there's many
food delivery apps out there but ours is
gonna revolutionize the market ours is
specifically going to leverage Google
cloud platform technologies and we're
gonna use it to show you how you can
leverage those technologies in your
mobile and desktop applications so let's
go ahead and jump over to the laptop and
I'll show you a quick demo of what we've
built here for you today I'm gonna do
something super taboo I'm gonna show an
iPhone and an IO demo cool so I know
this looks like a movie recording but
this is a real I'm using my iPhone so
you all can see that this is real we
have two apps here we have an app called
G eats and an app called G eats admin
I'm going to show you the G eats app
first so I'm going to go ahead and open
up the GE tap and this is the
application we've built here for you
today it's actually built using a
flutter can we get a shout-out for
flutter
sweet so even though I'm using an iPhone
this actually cross-compiled to Android
just fine using the same exact code so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
order from Googleplex googolplex is our
fictitious restaurant that we're working
with here today I'm gonna add a Caesar
salad because I'm on a diet I'm gonna
add some grilled cheese cuz I'm on a
diet and cheesecake because I'm on a
diet I don't know what kind of tight
y'all are on but I'm on a fun one so
here I have my Caesar salad my
cheesecake and my grilled cheese there
in my shopping cart and I'm gonna go
ahead and click checkout now in order to
fulfill our narrative our application
has had some fraud in the past
specifically people have stolen friends
iPhones and Android devices and ordered
you know it's the old order 10 pizzas to
your house trick so what we've decided
to do as a product team is implement a
text message verification so whenever I
click send confirmation my application
will generate a text message with the
total order cost it will send me that
text message and then I have to my mom
said she loves me and then I have to
reply yes or no to this text message so
we can see that the orders 1950 we have
a fun bug there it doesn't add the 0
after 50 so you know this is production
ready and I'm just going to go ahead and
reply yes and within a few seconds we'll
get a response back that says thank you
for your order it will arrive soon and
this is the kind of the consumer or the
front end application we've built and
it's a mobile application so let's go
ahead and jump back to the slides and
we'll talk about the technologies we
used here specific to Google cloud so if
you've ever built a mobile application
hope that was our video in case it film
we've done this before
so if you've ever built a mobile
application especially using flutter you
know that we use the standard material
UI components these are some stock
images nothing super complex there but
if you've ever built a mobile or desktop
application you know that sending and
particularly receiving a text message is
very difficult while you might be able
to leverage the local phone to send a
message
you don't have access outside of the
sandbox to receive that message into any
kind of processing with it so this is
where we need to leverage a cloud
service in order to send and receive
those text messages and this provides a
perfect opportunity for us to showcase
the first of many ways in which Google
cloud platform has invested in making
the coding experience for back-end
services and supporting services quick
and easy it all starts with code whether
you're a mobile developer or a desktop
developer or a firmware engineer it all
starts with code and for the past year
we've invested heavily in the developer
tooling ecosystem to bring you really
great developer experiences regardless
of the technologies you're working with
specifically we don't want you as a
mobile developer or an application
developer to have to provision servers
create users install packages install
security updates we want to do all of
that for you as a cloud provider some
people call this serverless it's the
idea that you give us your code and we
run it for you we scale it for you and
we keep it running for you while gaining
you giving you observability into it
let's go ahead and jump back over to the
laptop and I'll show you exactly what we
mean so here I have a very small node.js
application it's about a hundred lines
of code 105 to be exact it uses the
Express library and the important part
is that it has two endpoints the first
endpoint is send which you'll see right
here this accepts input from our
application or mobile application it
hits this send endpoint which then
communicates with our third party API
Twilio in this example to send a text
message to the user then we have another
endpoint which is verify verify receives
a web hook from our third party API
service whenever a user responds to a
text message it includes the body of the
text message and we can build branching
logic and process that response so
you'll notice here we have about you
know three or four lines of branching
logic here
where we see did the user say yes did
the user say no and otherwise we send
them in kind of a hot loop saying you
got to say yes or no to this order now
this is obviously like a fictitious
application we don't actually dispatch
an order to the Googleplex cafe because
it doesn't exist but you can get any
this gives you an idea and hopefully
some inspiration as to how you could
leverage a service like this to build
something very powerful but now what I
have this node.js code it's on my local
laptop now what do I do I obviously run
node locally and install and rock and
keep my laptop up in production all the
time that's probably not a great idea so
how can I get this code which is on my
local laptop to be running somewhere
that my users can access it and this
third party API can access it and this
is where Google cloud functions comes in
so I'm gonna go ahead and change
directory into our code file here and
inside here you'll see just do this
inside here you'll see our node
application and the important file that
I just showed you is that index.js file
that was the code that we were just
looking at now I want to deploy this
code to a publicly accessible endpoint
and I can do that using Google Cloud
functions so I'm gonna show you what
this code looks like and I'm great I'm
really bad at typing live on stage so
I've just typed this out as a script in
advance if you're not familiar with
scripting the first two lines just say
interpret this is bash the important
part is the g-cloud functions deploy
this uses g-cloud which is the Google
Cloud SDK you can install it on your Mac
on your Windows Device on your PC and
we're deploying a function called SMS
this is our kind of our SMS gateway if
you will I'm specifying the project in
which to deploy it the runtime in this
example we're using nodejs
we'll talk about some other runtimes in
a minute I'm giving it the entry point
where it should listen and finally I'm
telling it to be an HTTP trigger there
are other kinds of triggers like pub/sub
but for this example we're using HTTP
when I run this when I run this the
g-cloud deploy command will bundle my
code for me locally it actually bundles
it into a tarball it's
tarball up to the Google cloud platform
servers where the Google cloud platform
will build a binary distribution of our
application and run it for us and this
is Google cloud functions it's actually
just that easy to take code that you
have locally on your laptop and have it
running and an available HTTP endpoint
somewhere on the internet and by default
it doesn't have any authentication but
you can add your own authentication
either using your own frameworks or
using Google Cloud iam Identity and
Access Management so this is deploying
it takes about two minutes let's go
ahead and jump back to the slides and
we'll talk about Google cloud functions
in more detail for this particular
example we leverage Google cloud
functions to deploy our supporting
back-end SMS service our particular
function was written in nodejs but it
could have been written in Python or go
as well node Python and go are the three
languages that we support today in
Google Cloud functions and for many of
you in the audience you'll be excited to
know that we're currently in a private
alpha for Java support so if you're
leveraging Java technologies you'll soon
be able to leverage those in Google
cloud functions but what if you don't
use those languages what if you're using
some other language rust or Ruby or what
if you have additional requirements
beyond just a hundred lines of code
maybe you do have some system level
dependencies maybe you're interacting
with robotics so you need the robot
operating system available to you maybe
you need access to different things and
this is why we introduced cloud run just
a few weeks ago at Google cloud next
cloud run is the latest edition of our
serverless offerings remember we talked
about server lists we mean don't manage
any servers don't install any packages
with cloud run you package your
application and all of its dependencies
into this thing called a container or a
docker container and then cloud run
scales that container for you
automatically
you run the g-cloud command to deploy
your function to cloud run cloud run
will automatically scale your function
and it will even scale it down to zero
and this is very important
if you're an early-stage startup or a
midsize company that's tight on a budget
because with cloud functions and cloud
run you only pay while your code is
being run you don't pay if no one is
accessing that endpoint and if all of a
sudden you have a million users who are
all accessing that endpoint will scale
for you automatically and will
automatically scale back down when that
traffic alleviates that's code for you
now to tell you more about how you can
leverage AI and ml I'd like to invite my
colleague Dale on to the stage please
give it up for Dale thanks ed hi I'm
Dale I'm a developer for AI and Google
cloud so let's talk about how we can add
a little intelligence into our app to
make it easier to use and why might we
want to do that well you saw sets nice
flutter app for ordering food but let's
say that you're a restaurant and you
want to get listed on our app then you
probably have a menu that you need to
upload and your menu is probably analog
so you need to have somebody manually
type in all of the foods and prices and
all of this metadata to become listed in
the the g-d's tool and that's really
annoying especially if you're trying to
do this on mobile so can AI help make
that part of our app easier let me show
you how let's hop to the the phone I'm
clearly a pixel user all right cool so
you saw this nice app that Seth built
but let's look at the admin side that a
restaurant owner would use as you can
see in this interface there's no text
field for writing the foods or prices
instead we just upload a photo of our
menu that photo gets uploaded to the
cloud and analyzed and that analysis can
take a few seconds so let me show you
the picture that I just uploaded this
menu I was holding on stage and as you
can see there's lots of useful
information here like the name
of our cafe its address and phone number
plus all of this food information like
the headings salads mains the food items
and their prices so let's hop back to
the phone and oh look at that we got
lots of information from our menu
without even having to type it in let's
take a look at it so we identified
Googleplex cafe it's phone number and
address we also got these nice little
rating stars and a map showing where our
restaurants located and this cool user
generated a picture of the Google
headquarters we also did a pretty good
job of parsing the foods on the menu the
descriptions of veggie burger on a
pretzel bun I also want to point out
that this part wasn't a hundred percent
perfect like we didn't identify the
price of the chili or we thought that
cherry lime was a food and not a type of
gelato but we still saved a lot of time
and we can always go in and edit those
specific details so how did we make that
possible let's head back to the slides
so let's just recap what just happened
first I uploaded a photo then we extract
took the photo and extracted it into
text then we determine the location the
rating and we pulled some photos and
then we also parse the menu itself the
foods and their prices so how did we do
it to get the text we use the Google
vision API and once we had our menu in
text format we could pass it to the
Google now natural language API this
tool has lots of useful functionality
for analyzing text but we just spoke to
focused on the entity extraction feature
which finds substrings in our menu text
that correspond to prices phone numbers
addresses and more and once we extracted
that phone number that was very useful
because we could use it to query the
Google Places API so Google will take a
phone number and if it recognizes that
that phone number corresponds to a place
it can return your useful metadata like
the star rating of the restaurants
user-generated photos location and more
but actually the most difficult part
about building this app
identifying those menu specific entities
like that grilled cheese was a food and
that on a pretzel bun was a description
of a food because that's so specific to
our context of menu parsing that there's
nothing like in the box in a Google API
that recognizes these terms for that we
had to build a custom model and we did
that using a tool called Google Cloud
auto ml the way that works is you upload
a labelled training data set auto ml
builds a model for you and then it hosts
your model in a REST API that you can
call to get predictions but rather than
explain this let me just show you a demo
let's hop to the laptop so here I am in
the Google cloud platform console and
I'm in the natural language AI tool
space and there are lots of different
types of text models that we could build
but we're going to build an entity
extraction model that's for identifying
inline text items so our first step is
to find a data set and upload it right I
tried a few and this one worked the best
and so what happened was I found this
data set provided by the New York Public
Library of historical pictures of
historical menus that had been uploaded
and I used the vision API to extract the
text from them so let me show you what
that looked like
easy beef a restaurant in Virginia and
then I went in and I hand labelled all
of the entities that I cared about just
did that by clicking and dragging and
then saying ah a cheeseburger is a food
and after I did this for about two hours
I got really bored of labeling data this
is the very boring part of building
machine learning models but luckily
Google now offers a data labeling
service or if you want a data set like
this you can send it to the labeling
service Google will label your data and
then you'll be good to go
one thing I'll also point out is that I
didn't have a ton of menus to work with
in that data set only under 200 and
ideally when you're building a model
like this you really want more like a
thousand but as people use our app we'll
collect more data so
that's fine for now now we want to train
a model to be able to do that annotation
for us automatically and that's actually
the easiest part we just click start
training and then we'll get a pop-up
that says something to the tune of
alright come back in four hours and you
can see your model and then behind the
scenes Google will train a model for us
if we hop into this evaluation tab we
can see all sorts of useful metrics
about how accurate our model was and and
like I said more data means more
accurate so hopefully over time our
model will improve and then in the test
and use tab we can actually make
predictions so I think I opened this
because I couldn't I couldn't write a
menu on the fly but I came up with this
little fake menu I'll press predict and
we'll see if our model can correctly
identify the entities and as you can see
and identified all of the entities
imperfectly because that's machine
learning and machine learning has an
element of probability to it but if we
were to use this in our app it actually
does save us a lot of time inputting
data right because it identify most of
the foods and miss potato chips but it
was pretty good and then as users
correct us in the app we'll have more
data to retrain our model by the way
this is how to use the app in the
console but you can also hit it with a
REST API or through a number of client
libraries
all right let's hop back to the slides I
just showed you how to build an entity
extraction model but actually there are
auto emelles for all sorts of different
data types like photos video and more if
you want to learn more about this make
sure to check out my session tomorrow at
12:30 but with that I'll hand it back to
Seth
[Applause]
awesome Thank You Dale
so far we've showed you how Google cloud
enables you to focus on your code by
deploying scalable back-end services
using cloud functions or cloud run and
Daniel just showed us how to add
intelligence to our applications by
leveraging Google Cloud ml products like
Auto ml and I have to say that I'm an
engineer that focuses on infrastructure
and operations and prior to this talk I
had no idea about anything other than
machine learning besides magic and Dale
has taught me a lot about how we can
leverage different Google cloud
technologies without a PhD and machine
learning and I feel like an expert now
I'm not but I feel like an expert so
next let's look at how Google cloud can
help us with our builds specifically our
mobile application builds so we have
this Android application code again this
is flutter but it could be anything and
we have these AI models now what how do
I give that in the hands of my users now
I could leverage something like the
Android build studio locally on my
macbook that would build my application
I could publish it to the Google Play
Store
well my local laptop is not a hermetic
environment
I might have packages or users or
configurations that will cause my build
to fail or worse pass incorrectly by
linking to a system library or using the
wrong version of Java or the wrong
version of the Android SDK or NDK we
don't want this especially if you have a
many different developers especially
across many different organizational
units you want a consistent central
built environment where you can control
things like versions variable
substitutions packages etc and this is
where cloud build can come in cloud
build enables us to use the scale and
elasticity of the cloud to build and
publish our android applications with
cloud build we can build and test our
applications in isolated hermetic
environments leveraging the scale and
elasticity of the cloud most important
we only pay for the billed time that
we're using and there's a very generous
free tier to get started so with that
let's go ahead and jump over to the
laptop and I'll show you exactly what we
mean so I'm gonna go up here to my build
directory so in here I have an Android
application that's built using Gradle
now I totally could open this up in
Android studio I could click build I
could deploy it to a phone and I bet
that many of in the audience have
already done that before but how do I
get this in the hands of my users well I
could build it locally using the Android
studio with a production build but I
want to leverage the power of the cloud
for me to build this locally takes about
10 to 15 minutes with my dual core i7s
but what if I could use say 32 cores to
build this app that would hopefully be
very fast but at the same time it
guarantees that nothing on my local
laptop is interfering with the build
having it bit fail or pass improperly so
let me show you how we submit our
Android build to cloud build just like
before I have a script because I'm not
good at typing on stage let's jump down
to the very bottom where we have G cloud
build submit we're running a build by
submitting all of this code in this
directory all of these Android manifests
and Gradle Lu files were sending all of
that up to cloud build we're running our
build on a high CPU 30 tour core VM and
then we're passing in some substitutions
what are these substitutions well in
order to build an Android application we
need the Android NDK or we need the
Android SDK and potentially the NDK but
every time I build my application I
don't want to recompile the entire
Android SDK I don't want to have to
download it and install it and all of
the dependencies with cloud build what I
can do is I can cache those different
layers of my build steps so I can
download say the Android SDK 27 I can
cache that as a build layer and then
when I'm ready to deploy my application
I pull that build layer down and I just
build against it and then anyone else in
my organization that's building Android
applications builds against the same
base layer the same base image and that
guaranteed some consistency across
our applications I'm gonna go ahead and
run this now now there are three machine
types for cloud build we have a single
core an eight core and in this example
the 32 car I ran this particular build
across all three instance types takes
about 15 minutes on the single core
about 3 minutes on the 8 core in about 2
minutes on the 32 core which is what
we're using here today but I don't think
you all want to stand here and watch log
stream for 2 minutes so let's go ahead
and jump back to the slides we might
come back to this output if we have time
in a bit so let's recap what just
happened I have an Android application
code
I submit that code to cloud build and
cloud build can build anything
Ruby applications Python applications
today we're building an Android
application cloud build not only
compiles my application but it also runs
any tests that I have for me then it
uploads the compiled apk file to Google
Cloud storage which is our object store
from there you can download it load it
onto your test devices give it out to
trusted users for feedback what we
didn't do in our example today is
published directly to the Google Play
Store however you could use the Google
Play Store api's to publish directly to
a beta or test channel on the Google
Play Store and on the other side cloud
build actually integrates with source
control like github and git and supports
these concepts of build triggers so you
can imagine a world where you build a CI
CD pipeline for your Android
applications such that when you merge a
pull request or merge a change request
within 10 to 15 minutes that change is
available as a beta build to your users
all in an automated fashion only paying
while your build is running this is
truly leveraging the power of cloud but
now what we have our application it's in
a production hopefully we have some
users right now the G eats app is really
popular there's two users it's Dale and
I but now what we're done right no we
have to talk about observability how do
we gain in
sites and metrics into our application
so let's come up with another
hypothetical scenario or sorry let's
talk about observability first what is
this thing that I'm saying I'm saying
this word observability observability is
an umbrella term that describes things
like monitoring logging alerting
tracing dashboards and much more it
allows us to gain insights into a single
application but also how our
applications are communicating with one
another so now let's look at a
hypothetical situation let's say on
social media we get a message like this
hey I really love your new food delivery
app but sometimes it's really really
slow to get my text message
sometimes it takes nearly five minutes
to arrive and I'm really hungry
know as an application developer who's
generally internet savvy I could quickly
write this off clearly if they're not in
a good cell they don't have a good cell
phone reception that could explain the
latency right or maybe it's an issue
with their cellular provider in general
maybe it just takes their cellular
network provider time to deliver or
maybe they have an old phone can't
process the messages fast enough but
what if I could actually prove it what
if I could get a message like this from
my support team or my social team and I
could definitively go back to them and
say nope this is definitely not our
problem this relies somewhere else
outside of the chain that we don't
control and in order to do that we can
leverage a tool called Google Cloud
stackdriver stackdriver is a tool for
observability it provides integrated
logging monitoring alerting and tracing
across Google cloud that allows us to
gain better insights into our
applications performance let's go ahead
and jump in to the auto-generated
stackdriver chase dashboard to confirm
that our text messages were being
processed quickly so let's go ahead and
jump over to the demo laptop here I have
the Google cloud trace API dashboard in
our web console and I'm particularly
filtering on an end
point which I've coincidentally named
slow for the purposes of this demo now I
realized that some of you may not
understand what you're looking at so
give me a moment to explain it first
we're looking at the past hour of traces
which is a measure of the different
steps that our code is taking across our
different services on the left hand side
we're looking at a data point a sample
of a data point and on the the y-axis
its the latency or the total time it
took that request of a film so a dot
here for example took 20,000
milliseconds that's 20 human seconds
whereas a dot down here took 340
milliseconds that's less than half
one human second now we can look at this
and we can say that most of our requests
are down here at the very bottom which
is good it means they're being processed
very quickly ideally we want low low low
latency so we can see that most of our
requests are being processed in about
300 to 400 milliseconds which is really
good considering that's a mobile
application going over the public
Internet invoking our endpoint which is
communicating with a third party API and
then returning a response so 500
milliseconds for that round-trip is
really really good you'll notice that we
have a few here that are about 3 or 4
seconds but those don't concern me that
could just be Network latency but these
ones up here that's concerning to me
those are definite outliers they're 20
times and 40 times longer than any of
our other traces so let's take a look at
the difference here maybe we can gain
some insights into our code if I look at
one of these traces that took about 300
milliseconds scroll down a little bit
you can see that our endpoint was
dispatched then you know about 5
milliseconds later 10 milliseconds later
it actually hit our code and then about
3 milliseconds later we dispatched our
third party API very quick very fast
very expedient now let's take a look at
one of these outliers up here
now we notice something very interesting
our request again dispatched very
quickly there's only a few milliseconds
between when we hit our endpoint and
when our function was actually invoked
but then there's a huge block of time
almost 20 seconds until we call our
third party API this is actually an
indication to me that our initial
hypothesis is wrong this is a bug in our
code we're not waiting for the third
party API we're not waiting on network
latency this is all within my
application and I know that it's
happening inside the SMS slow endpoint
this gives me immediate insights into
where to go to look in my code for a bug
or a performance issue so let's take a
look at that and it turns out if we jump
down here to our slow endpoint there's
actually a random 10% of the time we
sleep for 20 seconds and there's a
really embarrassing to do here that I
was supposed to remove this before going
to production and this was just for
local testing and then we send a test
message and now I know no one in the
room has ever accidentally pushed local
test code to production but if you had
hopefully it's clear how a tool like
stock driver trace made it easy and
apparent that this was our fault and we
can go to our support team and we can
say hey your users are right 10 percent
of the time we were making them wait 20
extra seconds we fixed that it's not
going to happen again and we built
monitoring and alerting around it so
that we can proactively detect it in the
future let's go ahead and jump back to
the slides
so to recap today we discussed four
areas in which Google cloud platform can
improve your developer experience first
we talked about code we talked about how
you can leverage tools like cloud
functions and cloud run to build
scalable serverless applications to
support your mobile or desktop apps next
we talked about leveraging Google cloud
artificial intelligence and machine
learning products to build intelligence
into your applications without needing a
PhD in natural language processing or
machine learning then we showed how we
can leverage the power of the cloud to
build our applications on multi-core
vm's leveraging elasticity in a hermetic
and isolated environment and then lastly
once our application was ready to go we
saw how we can diagnose and analyze that
application when it's in the hands of
our users by tracing our back-end
services leveraging stackdriver trace
this is all been in service of one
high-level goal and if you're gonna take
anything away from this session today
this is what Dale and I want you to
leave with is that you should focus on
your code and let cloud do the heavy
lifting we're investing resources in
making sure that we are not getting in
the way of your core business we want to
support the business with these
different tools and technologies let
cloud do the heavy lifting if any of
this was interesting to you I'd like to
invite you to attend our other cloud
sessions you can click on cloud in the
app or on the mobile web interface
specifically I want to highlight these
four sessions for a general overview of
a many different Google cloud services
check us out on stage 7 at 2:30 tomorrow
as Jill already said she has a talk
later tomorrow about training a custom
machine learning model without any data
science experience required if you're
concerned about the security aspects of
this there's a really great session
tomorrow at 4:30 talking about how you
can secure your applications while
leveraging Google cloud and if you were
at all interested in that
serverless stuff Google cloud functions
Google cloud run App Engine App Engine
flex there's a great session tomorrow at
6:30 on making the right decisions for
your service architecture so with that
I'd like to thank you all very much for
coming
Dale and I will be happy to take
questions in the sandbox is down here on
the stage or feel free to tweet at us as
well thank you all so much
[Music]